Qué tan grave es para Trump este
veredicto civil especialmente de Cara a
su aspiración a ser candidato
presidencial
bueno primero que todo Muchísimas
gracias Bueno obviamente es decir hay
casos de casos verdad no solamente este
es uno de los este es uno de los casos
que está o que enfrentó Trump y que
sigue enfrentando Pero si lo vemos en el
esquema de las cosas pues este no
representa un grave daño político en el
sentido de que otros casos sí podrían
hacerme ya en sus aspiraciones a la
presidencia indudablemente la decisión
Del veredicto que escuchamos hoy pues
indudablemente es una mancha en su
imagen y de hecho él reaccionó ante el
ante la ante El veredicto diciendo que
esto era una cacería de brujas y su
campaña su equipo de campaña redobló
precisamente
ese reclamo pero me parece que más allá
de eso es una prueba contundente
precisamente para aquellas personas
especialmente de las mujeres dentro del
movimiento michu que están viendo
justicia y donde básicamente también se
reivindica una imagen que
de Donald Trump incluso antes del 2016
cuando en ese infame video con Access
Hollywood donde él hablaba de cómo él
digamos hacía a las mujeres por medio de
bueno sin necesidad de entrar en
detalles por supuesto por lo eso es del
contenido no pero pero creo que es un es
un hecho que muestra que no importa si
es si se es un presidente o un
expresidente Pues hay Hay consecuencias
por dichos actos y como usted mencionó
hay otros casos Por ejemplo yo le
menciono tres los documentos
clasificados que encontraron en la
residencia de Trump en mara lago por
presunta y también otro por
presuntamente falsificar registros para
sobornar a la estrella porno stormy
Daniels además de la investigación en lo
que lo acusan de interferir ilegalmente
en las elecciones del estado de Georgia
durante las presidenciales del 2020 Cuál
de esos procesos podría resultarle más
perjudicial
bueno indudablemente el caso que podría
estar que le podría representar peligro
es uno es su digamos involucramiento o
su presunto involucramiento en la
insurrección o lo que yo he llamado El
autogolpe de estado del seis de enero
que es un proceso que está llevando a
cabo Jack Smith que es el el consejero
especial y evidentemente lo que vimos en
Georgia de hecho como ustedes saben Hace
algunos días las personas que trabajaron
o que estaban al servicio de Donald
Trump firmaron un pacto de inmunidad con
lo cual ellos están tratando de revelar
vamos a ver qué revelaciones van a
encontrar pero ese es un hecho
contundente realmente y y creo que esos
son los dos de los casos que de verdad
podría representarle un grave problema
Pero obviamente todo todo depende de
cómo se desenvuelvan dichos casos por